We aim to make it easier and simpler for users
to shop the entire travel marketplace
for flights and for hotels.
We describe ourselves as a search driven online marketplace
We launched our Andriod app in early 2014
and since then, the growth has been really rapid.
There is an active community of developers out there
developing for the Android eco-system.
So it is really easy for our team to share their
experiences and also learn from other developers.
The move to material design was a natural progression.
We wanted to provide a more native experience
for our users.
And a user interface that they could simply just understand
and not learn specifically for WEGO'S app.
and for every new mobile app installed,
Last year when we decided to redesign our whole app
using materal design principles,
The first thing we did was to migrate to Andriod studio
which took a bit of getting used too.
Things went quite smoothly afterwards
with the help of new libraries provided by Google.
We moved to flatter material designs using
strong colours and bold typography
to focus attention on content.
The floating action button pushed
We optimized the app quite a lot
which made the app experience really good and really fast.
Within two months,
The most important thing that we are proud of is that
our app ratings were around
In a space of less than a year, we've improved that to
To grow your app ratings while scaling,
while still getting millions of new users
seems to be some of the best in the industry.